so next game against Dirk gentle
English name but from
Germany
2149 own number is now
2355 so the highest so far with
the
account so it looks like we're going
to produce Catalan again here or maybe
tarasch let's see somehow
a lot of them come into my bag without it
Maybe
I actually want to, so I'll play dc5 because I do
n't know bishop G5 C4 well,
so now Wirich has reached a relatively
normal Isolani position.
I'd like to play knight D4, oh
wait, it just depends.
D5 actually has some VP great move
against
hm, yes  Well, that could be a bit of
activity, a rook D8,
whatever, oh, yes, bishop F3 and knight D4
could be a problem here.
Maybe I
should think about it again if that was a good
idea,
it will definitely get a lot of weight
active
active game now
here knight D2 e.g. then one
possibility unfortunately can't
swap anywhere between and queen D3
looks looks like trouble Queen
H5 very unpleasant very
unpleasant
yes I shouldn't have taken that one
probably on
d5 knight D2
maybe rook D1 yes I see
not yet directly that it loses material
but it gives a dangerous
impression the only thing here at the moment I
think you is C8 rook C8 queen
G4 with attack double attack on E4 and
C8 but it is also pretty much the only thing
that is active here
yes what can be black
do
G6 so I'll still try Queen G4. I do
n't think I have that
many
squares. Now I'm hanging on
C8 F5 hm Queen
F4 h,
well not exactly nice but at least
he doesn't play that
fast.
Well, I don't see anything really great
either  But for him it
somehow looks like something is going on.
C8 is hanging normally but well, okay, he has
served it. Now at least E4 is still hanging
if I get a little bit of something exchanged
then most of the pressure is gone,
I assume,
so if he lets me now then I
have it  I have knight C3 and can
at least get rid of one of the central knights,
yes, okay, Queen
F4 G5 I then have to go to
E3 but maybe on maybe
I'm now threatening rook
C7
yes Queen D2 knight F3 unfortunately loses rook
C7, he can take f D and give check
to
E1  It's also nice and matt right away, so E2
also hangs
twice. Knight C3, maybe he can
take it to
F3. Yes, I have to move again first of all,
so in any case the knight had to come
back into
play,
I think what I didn't even have on my radar
exactly
G5 now K he of course Queen E3 then
swap and win back the pawn on F3
probably with a
good
position what about the move knight
D5 knight
D5 knight E2 bishop
E2 GF knight E7 check king
F7 rook C7 h I can't calculate
well you have to  at some point
pull
Check Check
time
warning black
resigns okay probably because he
thinks he won't make the time,
although now I think it
's quite good, F5 hangs and B7
hangs, it's actually too early to give up
but with only 20 seconds on the
clock  yes, of course that was kind of
strange, probably it wasn't
good, no D D5 there's so much
activity, let's get the computer to say what it
means, yes, just say knight knight
D2 knight D2 knight
D4 yes the computer is incorruptible in that position,
yes it sees that  of course
very bitter from ne drot knight E2
takes rook C1 yes black is of course
then of course better except for winning
but that also looked very suspicious
okay